hace como un año la vida nos cambió de
una manera radical era 6 de marzo el día
que se identificó el primer caso de
comida en el perú a los pocos días la
organización mundial de la salud la
declaraba como pandemia mientras que el
gobierno peruano le declaraba la
emergencia sanitaria a nivel nacional y
disponía un conjunto de medidas
destinadas a prevenir y controlar su
propagación en el país una de estas
medidas fue el aislamiento forzoso de
aquellas personas que viajaban
previniendo de países con kobe luego de
esa medida ya no fue suficiente y
pasamos al cierre de fronteras como
recordaremos todos otra medida que tuvo
un enorme impacto en nuestras vidas
cotidianas fue la suspensión de toda
actividad laboral de toda actividad
implicará no sólo laboral sino de toda
actividad que implicará la congregación
de muchas personas en espacios cerrados
a partir de ahí nuestra vida habitual se
transformó de una manera dramática
ya no íbamos al trabajo pero el trabajo
dentro de nuestras casas y si antes nos
quejábamos de largas jornadas laborales
ahora las jornadas parecían no tener fin
un día se sucedía al otro y los fines de
semana incluso eran un día más tuvimos
que aprender a organizar nuestros
tiempos para preservar nuestra salud
mental nunca como ahora se ha hablado de
la importancia en la salud mental y la
importancia de cuidarnos
así también el hogar de 8 millones de
estudiantes del país de educación básica
de escuela irrumpió en sus vidas y
rompió de sus hogares entonces junto con
la necesidad de aprender a convivir la
familia que antes salíamos de día de
noche y nos encontrábamos apenas los
fines de semana teníamos que aprender a
convivir teníamos que aprender a
organizar los tiempos laborales ahora
además en los hogares de los estudiantes
de educación básica y superior
en el acto educativo había ingresado a
sus hogares
este hecho y este contexto trabajo sin
duda mucho estrés pero también nos trajo
enormes aprendizajes
yo estoy segura que ustedes casi todos
vivían todos el 31 de diciembre cuando
alzaron sus copas para cerrar un año y
desearse lo mejor para el 20 y 21
dijeron una cosa en común palabras más
palabras menos en ha sido difícil ha
sido duro pero hemos aprendido muchísimo
nunca antes como ahora si hablo de la
salud mental si hablo de la importancia
de convivir y de convivir bien se habló
de la importancia de cuidarnos
comenzamos a cuidarnos comenzamos a ser
conscientes cuánto influye en la vida de
los demás nuestras decisiones en
nuestras acciones y que cuidarnos eran
no sólo cuidarnos a nosotros sino cuidar
a nuestros familiares en general a todas
las personas
y hemos aprendido mucho hay gente que
perdió empleo pero también muchos se
reinventaron y generaron emprendimientos
valiosos
sin duda ha sido un contexto muy duro
pero también un contexto de muchos
aprendizajes y si bien el mundo se puso
al revés la vida se puso al revés de
pronto algunas cosas que comenzaron a
funcionar bien nos hacían pensar si
acaso estaban al revés y ahora las
estamos poniendo al derecho
esta situación y me hacía pensar
muchísimo en un poema de mario benedetti
que se denomina transgresiones
una transgresión es una ruptura de una
norma o de un hábito de algo que hemos
normalizado pero creo que a estas
alturas hemos aprendido bastante bien
que muchas cosas que hemos normalizado
en realidad las tenemos que transformar
porque no son sanas porque no nos ayudan
benedetti en su poema precisamente
recoge este sentido este sentido de
provocación y de ruptura que tiene una
transgresión de ruptura para abrir dar
paso a algo nuevo y mejor
él dice bienvenidas sean las probables
transgresiones aquellas que nos permiten
enfrentar con osadía los mandatos
crueles entendiendo por mandato cruel
justamente esa situación que hemos
normalizado pero que en realidad estaba
al revés y teníamos que poner al derecho
con tanta pérdida que hemos vivido con
tanto dolor y sufrimiento y que trae
consecuencias que todavía la seguiremos
experimentando el haber hecho tan buenos
descubrimientos y el haber aprendido
tantas cosas valiosas bien vale la pena
que nos preguntemos cómo hacemos para
transformar la crisis en una oportunidad
y en educación es el ámbito donde esto
se ha reflejado de una manera mucho más
trascendental
el docente posiblemente la docencia es
la profesión que más ha sido recetada y
desafiada acostumbrados a tener el
aprendizaje como aquello que ocurre de
lunes a viernes de 8 a 1 en un espacio
llamado aula o escuela acostumbrada a
las familias a enviar a sus hijos a y de
ocho de ocho a una de lunes a viernes de
pronto las paredes de la escuela se
desaparecieron y entró la escuela al
hogar
así sin pedir permiso ahí están y ahí
estaban los docentes y los tutores y los
directores de nuevo mucho estrés y para
organizarse hubo familias que tuvo que
tuvieron que adquirir más dispositivos
para conectarte a través de internet
porque tenían que compartir la
computadora para el trabajo y también
para el aprendizaje y sin embargo
sacamos muchas lecciones
y generamos prácticas que son las que
deberíamos preservar en primer lugar las
familias comenzaron a ser testigos
directos en primera fila y comenzaron a
comprender y conocer y comprender qué y
cómo aprenden sus hijos a reconocer cómo
reacciona frente a sus docentes y frente
a otros compañeros a valorar al docente
mismo a darse cuenta como sus hijos
podían desarrollar mayor autonomía o no
y tenían que acompañarlos además de todo
este conjunto de descubrimientos también
las familias se convirtieron en actores
claves del aprendizaje transformaron su
rol de una manera radical de ser
simplemente los vigilantes de citi en
las tareas y luego recibir las notas a
ser aliados potentes de los docentes en
el acto de aprendizaje y eso que tanto
hemos buscado por años y años en la
escuela no un trabajo de colaboración y
que nunca se lograba ahora no sólo fue
necesario fue inevitable y entonces ese
fue un primer aprendizaje importante
para las familias un segundo aprendizaje
ya desde el lado de los docentes es que
descubrieron que las familias son
diversas y uno diría pero obvio son
diversas pero en la rutina diaria no
siempre ha sido así y no sólo
descubrieron que los diversas que son
pudieron comenzar a desarrollar una
mejor comprensión de cómo son sus
estudiantes de las particularidades de
los estudiantes en función de las
familias
pudieron establecer relaciones de
cooperación con los padres pero también
y acá viene un tercer aprendizaje
comenzaron a reconocer la particularidad
de sus estudiantes y comenzaron a
desplegar un aprendizaje mucho más
personalizado del que habían podido
lograr en el pasado porque ahora no
bastaba con organizar la sesión para un
conjunto de estudiantes al mismo tiempo
en realidad ahora tenía 25 espacios de
aprendizaje o 30 según fuera el número
de estudiantes y tenían que adecuarse
ahí y en ese ejercicio comenzaron al
reconocer cómo son sus estudiantes como
aprenden con qué ritmo que no es el
mismo para todos por igual
comenzaron a personalizar el aprendizaje
definitivamente
un cuarto un cuarto hallazgo en una
cuarta lección aprendida de este este
período es que así como las paredes del
aula tallerón y las familias se
ingresaron a mirar el aprendizaje así
como los docentes ingresaron al hogar
las puertas del hogar se abrieron así
también la realidad entró a la escuela
muchas veces hemos cuestionado que la
escuela y la vida están divorciadas y
hemos exigido y hemos demandado que se
eduque para la vida que realmente los
chicos aprendan a analizar a pensar ya
razonar pues bien esto ocurrió porque
todo el contexto que estábamos viviendo
la pandemia las reacciones de las
personas las medidas que se tomaban la
manera como íbamos evolucionando o no
evolucionando todo eso se convirtió en
materia de aprendizaje que podría
trabajarse tanto en matemáticas como en
literatura en comunicación en ciencias
en artes
es decir la vida misma entro a la
escuela
por consiguiente si bien tuvimos al
inicio esta sensación de que el mundo se
había puesto al revés al pasar las
semanas y los meses comenzamos a
percibir cuántas de las cosas que
creíamos que que ya habíamos normalizado
en realidad ya estaban al revés y las
estábamos trayendo al derecho a como
debía hacer a como debía funcionar mejor
la gran pregunta ahora es cómo hacemos
para que todo esto sea sostenible para
que el día que estemos vacunados el día
que la pandemia pase a ser un hecho
histórico pero ya no confrontadas a la
situación no volvamos a las viejas
normalidad es a esos mandatos crueles
sino que sostengamos ampliemos y
mejoremos todo aquello que hemos podido
recuperar en un año tan difícil
se necesita flexibilidad se necesita
capacidad de adaptación pero por
supuesto que también necesitamos
institucionalizar estas prácticas y creo
que tenemos un ejemplo que nos permite
ver cómo podemos hacer para que todos
estos aprendizajes se hagan sostenibles
a mitad del año pasado el ministerio
educación emitió una norma una norma muy
importante una resolución
viceministerial muy valiosa que decía
esta norma reconocía que los estudiantes
a lo largo y ancho del país no habían
tenido las mismas oportunidades que
estaban en desiguales condiciones
reconocían por lo tanto que no era
posible esperar que cerraran el año
habiendo aprendido todos lo mismo y de
la misma manera asimismo en la
resolución se dice que al inicio de este
año deberán evaluar los docentes a sus
estudiantes para saber en qué punto
están de su desarrollo y cómo construir
una ruta de aprendizaje que sea flexible
y se adecue a cada uno de sus
estudiantes
la verdad todo esto que he dicho y que
está en la resolución no es una
situación excepcional en realidad el
reconocimiento de lo que siempre ya lo
he dicho los chicos no son iguales no
tienen los mismos ritmos de aprendizaje
no podemos esperar que porque esté en el
mismo grado y tengan la misma edad
aprendan lo mismo y al mismo ritmo y de
la misma manera flexibilidad y
adecuación que son claves y una
respuesta resiliente es lo que
necesitamos conservar
estamos ante una ventana de oportunidad
es como que si hubiera abierto un túnel
del tiempo y podemos regresar al pasado
o podemos proyectarnos al futuro y hacer
que estas buenas prácticas se consolide
y que este año 2021 precisamente nos
dediquemos a reconocer todo lo bueno que
hemos hecho el año pasado de manera tal
que tanta pérdida tanto dolor y tanto
sufrimiento pueda
al mismo tiempo darnos algo valioso que
nos permita ser mejores personas mejores
profesionales mejores educadores mejores
familias mejores ciudadanas lo podemos
hacer depende de cada uno de nosotros
gracias
ah